einige von euch wissen wahrscheinlich
dass ich vor einigen monaten auf ein
fortnight video reagiert habe wo
senioren das spiel gespielt haben der
den noch ein stück vorjahr wo ja mach
alles alle ja das war schon lustig auf
jeden fall haben die senioren nun auf
meine reaction auf deren fordert video
reagiert also eine reactions action und
darauf reagieren wir heute wieder also
losgehen
hajduk gal lass uns noch mal zusammen
ford leidet spielen
ok ja eigentlich könnte ich vielleicht
doch was von euch hören aber ich glaube
es gibt noch schlechtere fordert spieler
und zwar seniorin bat gott sagt er
vertraut allein diese pläne dazu hat er
bedrohte sie wirklich immer noch mein
absoluter liebling ist kanal auf youtube
trifft na ja so einfach ist das sogar
die nacht wird wahrscheinlich gerade so
verwirrend sein mit dem ganzen face
camps hat der lacht sich tot
ja der lacht sich tot ist wer lacht sich
tot oder jung reagiert wechsel wird
diese kurzen und ganz schön dich mehr
hat und guckt dann kommentiert das sind
80 über uns toten zähler kann das auch
nicht spielen
die verdutzte er einfach da du bist war
er ist rüstig der das bild schon mal
gesehen wir unsere videos kommentieren
das freut mich später dass es lustig
findet ich glaube meine omas opas werden
noch schlechter da siehste da ist ja gut
dann sind wir haben wir ja schon ein
bisschen den vorteil hat diese meine oma
und opa die würden das überhaupt nicht
hinkriegen die leute du hast blaubär
gegessen weil blau der wände drauf dass
kinder auf die kinnlade zweite spaß
ikone und bedanke mich bei dir schön wie
hat mich geküsst
weiters war redet ist er wie blumenkohl
habe ich gesagt ja aus als ob werfen
blumenkohl sitze
denn eines darf da lache mich tot acht
das darf der hobby
ich bin wieder ganz gesund freut mich
der nacht so herzerfrischend der hat
richtig spaß davon
das ist doch okay ich bin's hammer wie
peter mittmann sagt das doch okay jetzt
richtig spaß dabei das doch vollkommen
in ordnung holz hinter hinten peter
witzig zu sein auch aus ich kann es
nicht ändern ich kann mich noch genau an
meine reaktion arbeit erinnern ich
konnte mich mehr verlagert und bei der
weit schon vorfreude ist luca du bist
wirklich witzig total vielleicht treffen
wir uns mal 'nen dann machen wir mal was
zusammen dann will ich mal sehen ob du
dazu kannst ich weiß nicht auf ihr das
auch in berlin aufnehmen dabei wenn ich
das nächste mal in berlin sein sollte er
melde ich mich was zusammen wortspielen
absoluter aber ich bedanke mich einfach
so ganz stumm getrunken als er wurde 49
sowie ich wurde in 49 cent das wäre ja
toll ja jetzt was dort und 40 ist doch
besser als 60 oder wie läuft der fließt
ja was meinst du wie der opa da hin und
her geht am tisch das ist sowieso eine
grabrede wie spielst du der nicht wieso
damals guck mal wie ich mit den fingern
hass brennt ist ja wirklich als ob ich
irgendwie vierhändig klavier spielen
will
obama fordert spielen mit klavierspielen
vergleichen irgendwo habe ich mein mann
knoten in die filiale ist es ja jetzt
bist du tot
manchmal ist der knoten drin ja was er
sagt sorry luca entschuldigung
angenommen ist kein problem dass du da
gestorben will
hallo luca das ist ja toll dass uns so
lustig findet wir lachen wir selber über
und aber vielleicht willst du mit uns
mal verleiht spielen du kannst es ja
auch nicht so gut hast du gesagt
war das noch
sage du kannst das ja auch nicht so gut
mein lieber peter wir sehen uns noch wir
grüßen dich ganz ganz lieb aus berlin
und wir hoffen dass wir dich bald mal
sehen und vielleicht machen wir mal was
zusammen auf jeden fall mega mega cooles
video geworden er mit einer gewissen
form so eine kleine nette an sage hey
luca du kannst erfordert auch nicht lass
doch mal gegeneinander spielen also mal
schauen was ich da noch so ergeht
freunde schreiben immer gerne in die
kommentare von bock drauf hätte dass ich
mal mit peter zusammen mit einem anderen
von senioren zocken fordert spiele wird
mich mal mega interessieren und das bei
dem video die auf jeden fall einen
daumen hoch da wenn es euch gefallen hat
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]
ein